All
[Music]
right, welcome everybody. Um, I'm Jeff
Huber, the co-founder and CEO of Chroma,
and I'm joined by Jason. We're going to
do a two-parter here. We're really going
to pack in the content. It's the last
session of the day, and so we thought
I'd give you a lot. Um everything in
this presentation today is open source
and code available. So we're also not
selling you any tools. Um and so
there'll be QR codes and stuff
throughout to grab the code. So let's
talk about how to look at your data. Um
all of you are AI practitioners. Um
you're all building stuff and uh this
probably these questions probably
resonate quite deeply with you. Uh what
chunking strategy should I use? Is my
embedding model the best betting
embedding model for my data? Um and
more. And our contention is that you can
really only manage what you measure.
Again, I think Peter Ducker is the
original who coined that. So, I can't
take too much credit. Um, but it
certainly is still true today. So, we
have a very simple hypothesis here,
which is you should look at your data.
Um, the goal is to say look at your data
I think at least 15 times this
presentation. So, that's two. Um, and
great measurement ultimately is what
makes systematic improvement easy. And
it really can be easy. It doesn't have
to be super complicated. So, I'm going
to talk about part one, how to look at
your inputs. And then Jason's going to
talk about part two, how to look at your
outputs.
So, let's get into it. All right.
Looking at your inputs. How do you know
whether or not your retrieval system is
good? And how do you know how to make it
better? Um, there are a few options. Um,
there is guess and cross your fingers.
That's certainly one option. Um, another
option is to use an LLM as a judge.
you're using, you know, some of these
frameworks where you're checking
factuality and other metrics like this
and they cost $600 and take three hours
to run. If that is your preference, you
certainly can do that. Um, you can use
public benchmarks. So, you can look at
things like MTeb to figure out, oh,
which embedding model is the best on
English. That's another option. Um, but
our contention is you should use fast
evals. And I will tell you exactly what
fast evals are. All right. So, what is a
fast eval? Um a fast eval is simply a
set of query and document pairs. So the
first step is if this query is put in
this document should come out. Uh a set
of those is called a golden data set and
then the way that you measure your
system is you put all the queries in and
then you see do those documents come
out. Um and obviously you can retrieve
five or retrieve 10 or retrieve 20. It
kind of depends on your application. Um
it's very fast and very inexpensive to
run. And this is very important because
it enables you to run a lot of
experiments quickly and cheaply. Um you
know I'm sure all of you know that like
experimentation time and your energy to
do experimentation goes down
significantly when you have to click go
and then come back six hours later. Um
all of these metrics should run
extremely quickly for pennies.
So maybe you don't have yet, you have
your documents, you have your chunks,
you know, you have your stuff in your
retrieval system, but you don't have
queries yet. That's okay. Um, we found
that you can actually use an LLM to
write questions and write good
questions. Um, you know, I think just
doing naive like, "Hey LM, write me a
question for this document." Not a great
strategy. However, we found that you can
actually teach LLMs how to write
queries.
Um, these slides are getting a little
bit cropped. I'm not sure why, but we'll
make the most of it. Um, to give you an
example. So, this is actually a um
example from one of the MTe kind of the
golden data sets around embedding
models, benchmark data sets. Um, this
also points to the fact that like many
of these benchmark data sets are overly
clean, right? What is a pergola used for
in a garden? And then the beginning of
that sentence is a pergola in a garden
dot dot dot dot dot. Um, real world data
is never this clean. Um so what we did
in this report um the link is in a few
slides. Um we did a huge deep dive into
how can we actually align queries that
are representative of real world
queries. It's too easy to trick yourself
into thinking that your system's working
really well with synthetic queries that
are overly specific to your data. Um and
so what these graphs show is that we're
actually able to semantically align the
specificity of queries synthetically
generated to real queries that users
might ask of your system.
So what this enables is, you know, if a
new cool sexy embedding model comes out
and it's doing really well in the MTB
score and everybody on Twitter is
talking about it, instead of just, you
know, going into your code and changing
it and guessing and checking and hoping
that it's going to work, um, you now can
empirically say whether it's good,
better or not for your data, um, and you
know, the kind of example here is quite
contrived and simple. Um, you know, but
you can actually look at the actual
success rate. Okay, great. These are the
queries that I care about. Do I get back
more documents than I did before? If so,
maybe you should consider changing. Now,
of course, you need to re-mbed your
data. That service could be more
expensive. It could be slower. The API
for that service could be flaky. There's
a lot of considerations obviously with
making very good engineering decisions.
Um, but clearly the north star of like
success rate of how many documents that
I get for my queries. Super fast and
super useful and makes your improvement
of your system much more systematic and
deterministic. All right. So we actually
uh worked with weights and biases um
looking at their chatbot um to kind of
ground a lot of this work. So what you
see here is for the weights and biases
chatbot um you can see four different
embedding models and you can see the
recall at 10 across those four different
embedding models. And then I'll point
out that uh blue is ground truth. So
these are actual queries that were
logged um in weave and then sent over.
And then there's generated. These are
the ones that are synthetically
generated. And we want to see is a few
things. We want to see that those are
pretty close and we want to see that
they are always the same kind of in
order of accuracy, right? We don't want
to see any like big flips between um
ground truth and generated and uh we're
really happy to see that we found uh
that answer. Now there are a few fun
findings here which is and of course
they're going to get crocked out but
that's okay. Um number one uh the
original embedding model used for this
application was actually text embedding
three small. um this actually performed
the worst out of all the embedding
models that we evaluated just for in
this case. Um and so probably wasn't the
best choice. Um the second one was that
actually if you look at MTeb Gina
embeddings v3 does very well in English.
It's like you know way better than
anything else but for this application
uh it didn't actually perform that well.
It was actually the voyage 3 large model
which performed the best and that was
empirically determined by actually
running this fast evval and looking at
your data. That's number three.
All right. All right. So, if you'd like
access to the full report, um, you can
scan this QR code. It's at
research.tra.com. There's also an
adjoining video which is kind of
screenshotted here, which goes into much
more detail. There are full notebooks
with all the code. It's all open source.
You can run it on your own data. And um,
hopefully this is helpful for you all
thinking about how again you can
systematically and deterministically
improve your retrieval systems. And with
that, I'll hand it over to Jason. Thank
you.
So, you know, if you're working with
some kind of system, there's always
going to be the inputs that we look at.
And so we talked about maybe thinking
about things like retrieval, how does
the embeddings work? But ultimately we
also have to look at the outputs, right?
And the outputs of many systems might be
the outputs of a conversation that has
happened, a you know agent execution
that has happened. And the idea is that
if you can look at these outputs, maybe
we can do some kind of analysis that
figures out, you know, what kind of
product should we build, what kind of
portfolio of tools should we develop for
our agents and so forth.
And so the idea is, you know, if you
have a bunch of queries that users are
putting in or even a couple of hundred
of conversations, it's pretty good to
just look at everything manually, right?
Think very carefully about each
interaction and then only use these
models when they make sense. And then
oftent times if I say this, they can
say, you know what, if we just put
everything in 03 and then here,
generally only use the language models
if you think you're not smarter than the
language model.
Then when you have a lot of users and
actual good product, you might get
thousands of queries or tens of
thousands of conversations and now you
run into an issue where there's too much
volume to manually review. There's too
much detail in the conversations and
you're not really going to be the expert
that can actually figure out what is
useful and what is good. And ultimately
with these long conversations with tool
calls and chains and reasoning steps,
these outputs are now really hard to
scan and really hard to understand. But
there's still a lot of value in these
conversations, right? If you've used a
chatbot, whether it's in cursor or any
kind of like cloud code system,
oftentimes you do say things like, "Try
again. This is not really what I meant,
you know, be less lazy next time." It
turns out a lot of the feedback you give
is in those conversations, right? We
could build things like feedback widgets
or thumbs up or thumbs down, but a lot
of the information exists in those
conversations. and the frustration and
the retry patterns that exist can be
extracted from those conversations and
the idea is that the data really already
exists in this conversation. If we think
of a simple example in a different
industry, you know, we can imagine the
analogy of marketing, right? Maybe we
run our evals and the number is 0.5. I
don't really know what that means.
Factuality is point6. I don't know if
that's good or bad is 0.5. The average,
who knows? But imagine we run a
marketing campaign and our, you know, ad
metric or our KPI is 0.5. There's not
much we can do. But if we realize that
80% of our users are under 35 and 20%
are over and we realize that the younger
audience performs well and the older
audience performs poorly. What we've
done is we've just drawn a line in the
sand on who our users are. And now we
can make a decision. Do we want to
double down on marketing to a younger
audience or do we want to figure out why
we aren't uh successfully marketing to
to the older population, right? Do I
find more part podcasts to market to?
You know, should I run a Super Bowl ad?
Now, just by drawing a line in the sand
and deciding which segment to target, we
can now make decisions on what to
improve. Whereas just making them ads
better is a sort of very generic
sentiment that people can have.
And so one of the best ways of doing
that is effectively just extracting some
kind of data out of these conversations
in some structured way and just doing
very traditional data analysis. And so
here we have some kind of object that
says I want to extract a summary of what
has happened. Maybe some tools that it's
used maybe the errors that we've noticed
the conversations that that happened.
Maybe some metric for for satisfaction
maybe some metric for frustration. The
idea is that we can build this portfolio
of metadata that we can extract. And
then what we can do is we can embed this
find clusters identify segments and then
start testing our hypothesis.
And so what we what we might want to do
is sort of build this extraction, put
into an LLM, get this data back out and
just start doing very traditional data
analysis, no different than any kind of
uh product engineer or any kind of data
scientist. And this tends to work quite
well. You know, if you look at some of
the things that Anthropic Cleo did, they
basically found that, you know, uh code
use was 40x more represented by cloud
cloud users than by you know uh GDP
value creation. they go okay maybe code
is like a good avenue and and obviously
that's not the really the case but the
idea is that by understanding how your
users develop a product you can now
figure out where to invest your time and
so this is why we built a library called
cura that allows us to summarize
conversations cluster them build
hierarchies of these clusters and
ultimately allow us to compare our eval
across different KPIs again so now you
know if we have factuality is 6 that's
really hard but if it turns out that
factuality is really low for queries
that require time filters, right? Or
factuality is really high when queries
revolve on, you know, contract search.
Now we know something's happening in one
area, something's happening in another.
And then we can make a decision on what
to do and how to invest our time. And
the pipeline is pretty simple. We have
models to do summarization, models to do
clustering, and models that do this
aggregation step.
And so what you might want to do is just
load in some conversations. And here
we've made some a fake data set, maybe
conversations, fake conversations from
Gemini. And the idea is that first we
can extract some kind of summary model
where there's topics that we discuss,
frustrations, errors, etc. We can then
cluster them to find cohesive groups.
And here we can find maybe you know some
of the conversations are around data
visualization, SEO content requests and
authentication errors. And now we get
some idea of how people are using the
software. And then as we group them
together, we realize, okay, really there
are some themes around technical
support. Does the agent have tools that
can do this? as well. Do we have tools
to debug these database issues? Do we
have tools to debug authentication? Do
we have tools to do data visualization?
Um, that's something that's going to be
very useful. And at the end of this
pipeline, we're sort of presented with
these printouts of clusters, right? We
know what the tools are, how the chatbot
is being used at a higher level, you
know, SEO, content, data analysis, and
at a lower level, you know, maybe it's
blog post and marketing. And just by
looking at this, we might have some
hypothesis as to what kind of tools we
should build, how we should, you know,
develop, you know, even our marketing or
how we can think about changing our
prompts. We can do a ton of these kinds
of things. And this is because the
ultimate goal is to understand what to
do next, right? You do the segmentation
to figure out what kind of new
hypotheses that you can have. And then
you can make these targeted investments
within these certain segments. If it
turns out that, you know, 80% of the
conversations that I'm having with the
chatbot is around SEO optimization,
maybe I should have some integrations
that do that. Maybe I should reevaluate
the prompts or have other workflows to
make that use case more powerful for
them. And again, the goal really is to
just make a portfolio of tools of
metadata filters of data sources that
allows the agent to do its job. And
oftent times the solution isn't really
making the AI better. It's really just
providing the right infrastructure.
Right? A lot of times if you find that a
lot of queries use time filters and you
just didn't add a time filter that can
probably improve your eval by quite a
bit right we have situations where we
wanted to figure out if contracts were
signed and if we just extracted one more
step in the OCR process now we can do
this large scale filters and figure out
you know what data exists
and generally the practice of improving
your applications is pretty
straightforward right we all know to
define eval but not everyone that I work
with has really been thinking about
something like finding clusters and
comparing KPIs across clusters. But once
you do, then you can start making
decisions on what to build, what to fix,
and what to ignore. Maybe you have a
two-sided uh quadrants, right? Maybe you
have low usage and high usage, and you
have high performing evals and low
performing evals, right? If a large
portion of your population are using
tools that you are bad at, that is
clearly the thing you have to fix. But
if a large proportion of people are
using tools that you're good at, that's
totally fine. If a small proportion of
people use something that do something
that you're good at, maybe there's some
product changes you need to make. Maybe
it's about educating the user. Maybe
it's adding some, you know, pre-filler
or automated questions to show them that
we can do these kind of capabilities.
And if there are things that nobody
does, but when we do them, they're bad,
maybe that's a oneline change in the
prompt that says, "Sorry, I can't help
you. Go talk to your manager." Right?
These are now decisions that we can make
just by looking at, you know, what
proportion of our conversations are of a
certain category and whether or not we
can do well in that category. And as you
understand this, then you can go out,
you can build these classifiers to
identify these specific intents. Maybe
you build routers, maybe you build more
tools. And then you can start doing
things like monitoring and having the
ability to do these group buys, right?
So now you have different categories of
query types over time and you can just
see what the performance looks like,
right? where 0.5 doesn't really mean
anything but whether or not a metric
changes over time across a certain
category can determine a lot about how
your products is being used. By doing
this we figured out that you know some
customers when we onboard them they they
use our applications very differently
than our historical customers and we can
now then make other investments in how
to improve these systems and ultimately
the goal is to create a datadriven way
of defining the product roadmap.
Oftentimes it is research that leads to
better products now rather than products
justifying some research that we don't
know is possible.
And again the real marker of progress is
your ability to have a high quality
hypothesis and your ability to test a
lot of these hypotheses. And if you
segment you can make clearer hypotheses.
If you use faster evals you can run more
experiments. And by having this
continuous feedback through monitoring
this is how you actually build a
product. Right? This is regardless of
being an AI product. This is just how
you build a product.
And so if you look at the takeaways
really when you think about measuring
the inputs, we really want to think
about not using public benchmarks,
building evals on your data and focusing
first on retrieval because that is the
only thing a LLM improvement won't fix,
right? If the retrieval is bad, the LLM
will still get better over time, but you
need to earn the right to sort of twink
tinker with the LLM by having good
retrieval. And then lastly, if you don't
have any customers or any users, you can
start thinking about synthetic data as a
way of augmenting that. And once you
have users, look at your data as well.
Look at the outputs, right? Extract
structure from these conversations.
Understand, you know, how many
conversations are happening? How often
are tools being misused? What are the
errors? And how are people frustrated?
And by doing that, you can do this
population level data analysis, find
these similar clusters, and have some
kind of impact weighted understanding of
what the tools are. Right? It's one
thing to say, you know, maybe we should
build more tools for data visualization.
It's another thing to say, hey boss, 40%
of our conversations are around data
visualization and the, you know, the
code engine or the code execution can't
really do that well. Maybe we should
build two more tools for plotting and
then see if that's worth it. And you can
justify that because we know there's a
40% of the population is using data
visualization and we do that, you know,
maybe only 10% of the time, right? This
is impact weighted. And ultimately as
you compare these KPIs across these
clusters, you can just make better
decisions across your entire product
development process. So again, start
small, look for structure, understand
that structure, and start comparing your
KPIs. And once you can do that, you can
make decisions on what to fix, what to
build, and what to ignore.
If you want to find more resources, feel
free to check out these QR codes. Uh the
first one is the Chroma cloud to
understand a little bit more about their
research. And the second one is actually
a set of notebooks that we've built out
that go through this process. So we load
the weights and biases conversations. We
do this cluster analysis and we show you
how we can use that to make better
product decisions. So there's three
Jupyter notebooks in that repo. Check
them out on your own time. And uh thank
you for listening. We do have time for
we do have time for like one quick
question and of course as well outside
as well. So thank you if anybody wants
to grab the mic there and over there.
Y
for spicy. What's the spicy take today?
It's not KPI, by the way. That's not the
spicy. I think I think more agent
businesses should try to price and like
price their services on the work done
than the tokens used. Yeah. Price on
success, price on value. Very unrelated
to this talk, but
[Music]